all right we saw some boom we saw just a
little bust from josh allen earlier in
the hour but we have concluded there's a
ton of potential there he could end up
being a great nfl quarterback but that
has inspired today's draft on pro
football talk live the biggest boom or
bust players for 20 20 chris sims
you have the trivia question for me i
would like to go boom chances are i'll
go bust
let's see what you got i know i'm gonna
get it wrong but let's see what you got
no you got a chance today i think you
really do here we go josh allen had the
third most rushing yards of any qb last
season lamar jackson was obviously first
we know that who was sandwiched in
between them who was the quarterback
with the second most rushing yards
behind lamar in front of josh allen
oh see i want to say kyler murray but i
think if i recall correctly he didn't
what should i say kyler murray
what are you trying to do to me sims
yeah you're right
you're right i i was trying to do that
for you to think like oh no it must not
be kyle or murray it's gotta be somebody
else darn it
i know but when you really start to
think about it you just go yeah who else
would even be there in that conversation
right so it's like you almost have to
pick kylie murray yeah yeah it ain't
gonna be matt ryan uh right
yeah and
but but you just i thought there was
maybe like some curveball was going to
surprise me that the i don't know but
but kyla murray didn't run as much as we
thought he was going to and that just
speaks to the skill of kyler murray even
when he doesn't run as much as you think
he's going to he's still second in the
league in rushing which that guy i i
he's not a candidate for boomer bust for
me he is all boom no bust kyle murray is
going to be incredible this year so that
is not my first pick look the most
obvious one to me and it doesn't have to
be a young player right it can be
anybody boomer this is the year we find
out what the guy is right your guy
odell
beckham
jr
this is the boomer bust year this is the
year we find out is he the 2014 otto
beckham jr or is he done is he destined
to just be you know around a thousand
yard a year guy but not that game
breaker that is going to make people go
ooh and awe and think that he's the best
receiver in the league and potentially
one of the best of all time this is the
year we find out which way obj is going
to go you like that one don't you well
you know listen i'm not going to argue
it i mean i know what you're saying like
yeah
odell beckham jr has set a standard for
himself where
bust is like a thousand yards receiving
now i mean basically so you're right and
of course he's uh other than tom brady
the most popular player in our sport
still
even with being on some underwhelming
teams here for the last few years and
it's a huge year in cleveland
as we both know i mean you could
probably put baker mayfield in this
conversation a little bit for that type
of conversation as well but i'm with you
and i'm expecting big things from obj
this year it's very quiet off season
he's been talking about his work it
working hard and coming back to have a
huge year so i would be shocked if it's
not boom uh i think it's going to be
boom all the way all right you know but
there's no middle ground that's the key
there's no middle ground
he's going to be perceived as a
tremendous success
or an abject failure it's not going to
be oh okay he was just fine this year so
i think that's how you define this and i
think it's right i agree i agree with
you but i don't always think that's fair
either you know again i think a lot of
people look at last year and go it was a
bust and i want to go no it was a
thousand yards receiving that's crazy it
wasn't a bust it just wasn't what we
wanted it to be or what we expected it
to be so uh but i'm with you a huge year
there all right i'm going with the older
guy too in fact i'm going much older all
right i'm going with phillip rivers i
think that's a big boomer bus prospect
right there you know i i i if we were
sitting here in january and you go hey
the colts are the number two seed in the
afc i would go i'm not shocked that's a
good roster and phillip rivers had some
you know has shown the capabilities to
be a really good quarterback still uh
but also if we were sitting here and we
went the colts went seven and nine and
didn't make the playoffs and phillip
rivers was leading the league in
interceptions or sec i wouldn't be
shocked that that happened either i
would not so uh yeah to me the philip
rivers experiment is boom or bust i can
see it either being great or it's going
to be underwhelming and we go hey philip
great career you know now it's time to
retire and the colts need to find a new
quarterback
yeah you know he was at the top of my
list as well i thought about making him
the first pick because you're right that
there is no
yeah yeah it's a pretty good year
phillip no he's either going to be great
with the colts or we're going to be
saying in mid-october what in the hell
were the colts thinking when they signed
this guy so i agree with you on that all
right next one for me another guy who uh
look i i think we're we're at the
tipping point and i think this is his
last chance to convince his team that
he's the guy to lead them into the
future and that's jimmy g your guy in
san francisco right they had the
conversation about tom brady you took it
even farther than that with the things
that you heard from multiple different
sources and multiple different camps
that they really did take a close look
at the possibility of trying to upgrade
from garoppolo to brady garoppolo heard
all that they told him about all that
that's what gm john lynch acknowledged
and for look hey he's either going to
shake
from his psyche the fact that he was
completely marginalized and undermined
in the playoff games because they just
ran the ball ran the ball ran the ball
after they got freaked out by what
should have been three interceptions
against the vikings before the middle of
the third quarter and decided to just
run the ball down minnesota's throat
they hardly used him in the nfc
championship game he had emanuel sanders
open and missed him in the super bowl um
he's either going to respond to that and
find a new level or he's going to
continue to do those kinds of things and
at some point the 49ers are going to say
you know if we could just add a high-end
quarterback to this team we'd never lose
a game
yeah i think that's fair jimmy g was on
my list certainly you know do i look at
it and think he's a little overly
scrutinized yeah i do certainly but i
also understand it i do when you know
when you're talking about a team where
hey they were really talented we know
that and there were some big moments
that were a little underwhelming by
jimmy garoppolo and of course didn't
come through in the big moments and you
know to your point mike it did look like
they had to manage him in the playoffs a
little bit and be careful about what
they did and didn't do with him so
i do i think this is a huge year for him
for his future and you know you i think
you look at the contract situation this
is the year the 49ers could get out of
this too and really have no issue too so
that adds to that conversation as well
man
okay i think my next pick i'm gonna go
with grunk uh gronk is boom or bust to
me i mean yeah i just don't see you know
a little like odell beckham jr the
expectations of course are very high
right so
bust is like okay yeah it's a good year
for a lot of tight ends but not for the
greatest tight end in the history of the
sport and you know hey let's not forget
you know he's taking a year off from
football and his last year playing
football it was only 682 yards receiving
and three touchdowns so i could see this
year being boom 800 yards and nine
touchdowns 10 touchdown catches or i
could see man gronk has lost a little
bit of a step he's banged up he's having
a hard time finding his niche within
this offense and it's like four or 500
yards receiving and just like two or
three touchdowns i wouldn't be shocked
if it went either way i don't think
there's going to be much of a middle
ground here
uh and i'm going to disagree with you
because i think this very potential to
be well but here's the thing i think
what we may see is perceived bust in the
regular season delayed boom in the
postseason when they didn't trade oj
howard or cameron breit it occurred to
me that you know they're thinking
remember the 20 what 2018 season is last
year with the patriots
keeping him healthy into the postseason
is the key to winning in the post season
so brady's gonna want a hundred percent
gronk in january
we'll use oj howard and cameron brayton
mike evans and chris goblin we've got
all the weapons now we don't need to use
gronk extensively during the regular
season as we get closer to the post
season he gets into closer and closer
into full football shape that's when you
unleash glock so so the numbers may not
be there but i think the performance
will be there the impact will be there
down the stretch all right last one for
me man i got a lot on my list i know
um uh we've already done a quarterback
let me go with a running back a lot
we've got a receiver we got a
quarterback i'm gonna go with the
running back this is it for le'veon bell
this is it this is it this is the he's
either the guy that he was in pittsburgh
or he's just not and he'll be done with
the jets after this year and he will be
relegated to finding whatever he can on
the open market next year around five
six million a year at the absolute most
le'veon bell has got to prove there's no
middle ground there's either going to be
this is our guy and he's the guy he was
in pittsburgh anything short of that and
they're going to cut him after this year
and he's going to go into that that
churn of veteran running backs just like
with devante freeman now just kind of
hanging around just kind of waiting for
the phone to ring and and being offered
amounts that are so far short of what
they're used to making that they're
going to refuse to take them
yeah i think it's a huge year for
le'veon bell uh agreed it was it was
underwhelming last year and i also don't
know if the jets did everything they
could to really help them out or
accentuate the things he can do and be
successful with i mean there's there's
no doubt about that they've improved
their offensive line so that should help
and hopefully he'll be in better
shape and football shape than he was a
little early on there last year man i
got so many too i'm not sure here all
right i'm gonna go i'm going to
quarterback again i'm going with matthew
stafford and listen hear me out i don't
expect bust like bad play for matthew
stafford i just think it's a boomer bust
year for either he stays in detroit for
the next three to four years or this is
it and i mean this is in totality like
you know hey yeah one maybe he just
plays average or a little above average
and they want to move on to a new
quarterback or he plays good and the
team kind of fails and he just says i've
had it with this place you know we've
heard he's sailing selling his house and
he's gonna go damn i'm out of here i've
had it detroit can't get it done and
figure it out i need to go play
somewhere else so i think it's a big
boomer bust year as to the future of
matthew stafford in detroit uh i think
it's getting very close to have run its
course there
all right and we gotta go but i had a i
had a lot of other names on my list tom
brady judy smith schuster stefan diggs
sammy watkins derek carr twice i put
derek carr on the list
jared brandon cooks
and and and my buddy kirk cousins goes
on the list as well let's take a break
more please
right after this
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports